bom a noite é eu queria começar levando
vocês numa viagem à pré-história ao ano
11 a gerente do google que em 1997 que
foi o ano em que com esse apresentação
eu me integrei a uma redação nas
primeiras reações no brasil a produzir
conteúdo exclusivo para a internet
dentro de uma da grande imprensa
brasileira
até então a prática normal era o que a
gente chamava de choveu air show epa é
que era pegar com uma paulo conteúdo
produzido para o veículo impresso e
jogar na internet a partir do momento em
que concluiu se isso não é uma boa idéia
legal começar a produzir coisas
realmente que fossem pra internet com
cara de internet é bom chegamos a essa
conclusão ao meu chefe e virou para a
equipe falou olha
nossas pesquisas mostram que existem
três coisas que atraem realmente atrair
as pessoas na internet pornografia e
esportes ciência com pornografia a gente
não trabalha e sport não gostava então
eu fui para a ciência é a internet
naquela época 97 do jeito que a gente
conhece hoje ela ainda estava começando
com ela a internet como uma rede aberta
pra para o público em geral aberta para
interesses comerciais é um fenômeno
recente ainda era do acesso discado das
grandes empresas de mídia ainda não
sabiam exatamente o que fazer com ela
tinha muita discussão se vale a pena
manter uma presença na internet 80 esse
negócio fogo de palha daqui a pouco
ninguém mais vai querer usar etc e bom
por conta disso é fazer jornalismo para
internet nessa época muitas jornalismo
sobre a internet explicar às pessoas o
que é a rede que elas vão encontrar lá
por quê serve esse espaço etc
eu ia ea minha área eu tinha que fazer
isso fazer o mesmo sobre internet e
sobre ciência na internet
bom mas eram as principais pautas de
ciência divulgação científica em 1997 é
óbvio houve várias claro mas eu vou me
concentrar em duas aqui que explicam
mais ou menos o gol um tanto quanto
bizarro que a minha carreira acabou
tomando uma delas é o lançamento da
sonda cassini vocês devem se lembrar
missão acaba agora em setembro
marco anos um sistema de saturno e fez
várias muitas imagens bonitas fez várias
descobertas importantes etc
bom em 97 a sonda foi lançada todo mundo
diz sobre isso nos jornais na internet
uma coisa que as pessoas podiam
encontrar sobre a cassini era algo
chamado stop cassini stop no sentido de
paris detém a impeça era um movimento
organizado movimento social talvez para
chamar organizado online de repente
talvez um dos primeiros grandes
movimentos organizados pela internet
cujo objetivo é impedir que a sonda foi
lançada porque porque eles achavam que
houvesse um acidente durante o
lançamento
a sonda espalharia plutônio pela
atmosfera da terra isso seria um
desastre ambiental
bom isso é uma bobagem a nasa teve que
gastar tempo esforço e dinheiro
produzindo conteúdo para explicar que
isso era uma bobagem
a coisa chegou judiciário nos estados
unidos
alguns jornalistas amigos meus no brasil
chegaram a embarcar nessa história de
que o lançamento do cassino era uma
ameaça tal e eu me vi obrigado escreveu
explicando que isso era bem assim
é segunda o grande ponto importante de
ciência nos seus 97 a chegada da missão
mas pra entender a marte foi o primeiro
robozinho sobre rodas a descer em marte
foi a primeira missão espacial a gerar
imagens diretamente pela internet
muita coisa legal também a cobertura da
mídia impressa é enfatizou muitos
aspectos mas na internet que as pessoas
encontravam sobre isso um monte de gente
que ficava olhando as fotos que ela
mandava online nos mínimos detalhes
falando isso é uma pirâmide
isso é uma estrutura alienígena que a
gente entrou no photoshop e construiu um
cilindro que nem pareciam aquelas coisas
de 15 anos 50
bem na frente da do robozinho e de novo
como eu te escrever sobre ciência para
internet sobre internet eu fui lá
explicar que as coisas não eram bem
assim
passam se alguns anos começa a circular
pelos meios brasileiros uma denúncia de
que havia um livro didático nos estados
unidos que mostrava que a amazônia uma
área sob intervenção internacional
e chegou a ter uma versão muito
sofisticada disse que era uma página do
livro escrito em inglês macarrônico
assim muito engraçado é dizendo que a
onu tomou posse da amazônia porque os
brasileiros são irresponsáveis
incompetentes não consegue tomar conta
daquilo
talvez essa fosse a única coisa
verdadeira da do hawks mas enfim eu tive
que escrever explicando que não era bem
assim pode explicar que não é bem assim
explicar que não é bem assim eu me vi de
repente numa carreira em que é o meu dia
a dia escrever sobre o atlântida deuses
astronautas é o pé grande e do estado
matemática é ótimo que o nosso consumo
da foto pessoal achou tudo remete à
enfim coisas dessas
monstros e vários tipos de linhas da
conspiração aaa a internet sempre foi um
celeiro da conspiração uma outra coisa
também que me deu um trabalho é majestic
hotel majestic 12 não sei se algum de
vocês acompanham uma série de tv em
antigas que tratavam disso os papéis bem
feito até uma fraude bem bolada coisa
tática gravadas nessa escaneado com
carimbos top secret confidenciou tal
dizendo que eu venho estados unidos
tinham um acordo com os alienígenas
cinzentos para que eles pudessem
seqüestrar pessoas impunemente então
isso foi ontem a gente consegue escrever
explicando que não era bem assim
enfim eu acabei construindo uma carreira
de duas décadas basicamente tratando do
incrível extraordinário fantástico
idiota e é divertido assim você escrever
sobre explicando que as pirâmides do
egito foram construídas pelos egípcios e
não pelos venezianos é interessante tal
é você aprende coisas mas ele começa a
perceber outras coisas que não são bem
assim que não são tão legais estilo
gente dizendo que a vacina causa autismo
o que dá pra curar o câncer com com
dietas trocas e esse mundo das coisas
que não são bem assim
eu tenho um lado sinistro e muito
perigoso ano passado quando a
a o pânico por dia assim como a palavra
muito forte quando a preocupação com
notícias falsas
após verdade e fatos alternativos e meio
que chegou a consciência global todo
mundo meio que acordou para isso a
primeira coisa que eu pensei foi bem
vindos ao mundo
agora vocês sabem como eu me sinto
virava o pessoal que trabalha com
política economia falando eu já achava
que sim será fácil né e legal bom
a segunda coisa que eu pensei foi essa
minha experiência acumulada de 20 anos
nessa nessa trincheira com o é o falso
ou quase falso o mal explicado
o pseudo o pseudo científico pseudo
factual que eu aprendi que ferramentas
eu desenvolvi esse mesmo tempo que pode
ajudar as pessoas que agora estão no meu
mundo a navegar nesse mundo que será que
eu consigo uma espécie de guia de safári
alguma coisa e depois refleti eu cheguei
a uma caixa de ferramentas que é
basicamente composta por três perguntas
são três perguntas que eu isso eu quero
deixar para vocês aqui hoje que eu
sugiro fortemente que vocês se não
favorece não façam explicitamente pelo
menos sempre tenham em mente tenham elas
incomodando aqui atrás na no fundo no
fundo da cabeça
sempre que alguém tentar convencer vocês
alguma coisa
as perguntas são do que você está
falando o que exatamente você quer dizer
e como você sabe que isso é verdade
tentar expandir um pouco do que você
está falando é a questão filosófica
básica da definição dos termos é uma não
só vezes em termos de apelo emocional
democracia liberdade tal que querem ver
coisas diferentes para pessoas
diferentes mas também há há há contextos
pouco mais concretos em que essa dúvida
pode surgir por voltando pra minha área
da ciência vida fora da terra você falar
você acredita em vida fora da terra o
que quer dizer com isso ele quer dizer
treinos você acredita em vinhos verdes e
não se acredita em pirâmide de marte ele
tá perguntando se você acredita que
talvez existam microrganismos no subsolo
mas se a vida
até pode ser uma dessas coisas agora o
que exatamente você está dizendo ao
cargo ele está falando de micro
organismos marcianos ok
o que você tá falando desse mecanismo
podem falar
ele pode estar falando que talvez
existam que seria ligado a nós a mandar
mais sondas para lá para tentar
determinar isso que essa é uma questão
interessante ele por tentando dizer que
esses microrganismos chegaram aqui na
terra estão causando o aquecimento
global por exemplo é é a especificidade
da alegação é muito importante ea
terceira questão como você sabe que isso
é verdade é a famosa é busca por
evidências é pra citar um clichê que
causei cantor famoso ligações
extraordinárias requerem evidências
extraordinárias que se a pessoa diz pra
você que tem um palhaço distribuindo
doces mas que não está mesmo tá legal
possível registrar isso e pronto
se a pessoa disser pra você que tem um
alienígena de secando criancinhas mas
que não talvez você precise de um pouco
mais de informação antes de aceitar isso
como como verdade eu digo essas
perguntas são importantes pra fazer pra
ter em mente quando alguém tenta
convencer a gente de alguma coisa e esse
alguém tentar convencer a gente de
alguma coisa não me referindo apenas à
comerciais de tv ou apelos que vêm para
as redes sociais tal mas eu estou me
referindo também muito principalmente
isso é uma coisa importante nesse mundo
de redes sociais onde as fontes que a
gente tem hoje em dia pi causa por causa
do facebook do twitter são um país muito
nossos amigos nossos parentes são
pessoas que a gente ama a pessoa que
você ama pode estar compartilhando algo
de um de outra fonte de um conteúdo de
um jornal de um site
mas quando chega você cria como algo que
aquela pessoa em quem você confia
compartilho mas o fato de que alguém que
você ama se deixou enganar o foi
enganado foi ingênuo não obriga você a
se deixar enganar solidariedade quer
dizer é importante dessas perguntas em
mente até mesmo quando a gente lida com
pessoas que são importantes para a gente
com as coisas vêm do que parece ser uma
fonte próxima
é e confiável porque assim dizer quem
quem convence a gente quem controla
aquilo que a gente acredita quem
controla também ao fim ao cabo como a
gente se sente o que a gente faz lembra
do pessoal do stop cassini organizar um
movimento porque estava convencido de
uma coisa de que o lançamento da sonda
era um perigo para o meio ambiente no em
escala planetária
realmente você acredita que o fenômeno x
1 pelo meio ambiente você tem obrigação
moral de combater este fenômeno é esta
então o controle da crença e se este
serviço de porteiro da consciência é uma
coisa muito importante ea minha sugestão
é que essas três perguntas por que você
está falando o que exatamente você quer
dizer como você sabe são uma boa forma
de controlar isso
e eu falei é tomar cuidado ter
simplesmente com a gente conversa com
outras pessoas quando a gente recebe
coisas até de quem a gente ama e também
manter essas questões em mente para nós
mesmos para a auto exame porque o ser
humano animal teimoso
quando a gente assimila uma ideia como
verdadeiro é muito difícil se livrar
dela mesmo ela sendo falsa
as pessoas acham que a inteligência é
uma vacina contra isso ficaria muito eu
sou muito inteligente eu eu eu queria
alto eu estudo na universidade de
primeira linha
se eu fui convencido de alguma coisa se
eu acredito muito em alguma coisa ela
deve ser verdade talvez não há pessoas
muito inteligentes são muito boas em
criar defesas para crenças indefensáveis
então era basicamente isso que eu queria
deixar para vocês sugerir isso que vocês
tenham essa ferramenta essas três
perguntas sempre em mente antes de
deixar alguma coisa passar a a barreira
do senso crítico do que você está
falando o que exatamente você quer dizer
e como você sabe e agora prá então pra
pensar eu queria sugerir um exercício
estou aqui falando pra vocês a mais de
15 minutos
então agora enquanto fizer o meu longo
caminho de volta e gostaria que vocês se
perguntassem o que esse cara tava
falando o que foi que ele disse e como
ele sabe
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]